[Musik]
als wunderschönen guten morgen melde
damen und herren es ist gerade acht uhr
27 ich bin tot wie ein toter mensch der
joker warum mittel sondern 830 bach na
ja meine damen und herren nicht mit den
damen und herren wachst du dich nach
halle schon damals wurden das haben wir
alles wurst drama meister in dortmund
sonne youtube lifestyle fashion fashion
das ist ja eine festmesse wenn ich das
theoretisch mit den jockey hinkommen
warum sich lehrer ganz im ernst wenn ich
jetzt mit ganz normalen messe gewesen
wäre
ich würde also irgendwie einfach so
winterlich kalt kein blog gemacht aber
da sind halt auch viele andere youtuber
auf der messe sind zum beispiel unter
anderem thema
das unternehmen das von von den anderen
autofahrer jetzt wahrscheinlich eher
luca was macht ihr denn auf einer
fashion leisten der musikmesse
das ist eine sehr gute frage da suche
ich mir so sehr modernen supermarkt
ketten und ich wir hatten schon häufiger
ten treffen und haben uns dabei
vertreten weil ihm ein gelato cases mega
heiß werden zu treffen und sich zu
unterhalten allerdings hatte man nie so
wirklich so viel zeit wie man wollte für
eine person die man das wie ihr wisst
was ich meine zweite was das sollte
angaben man hat foto gemacht man hat
sich irgendwie erhalten und so weiter
und so fort dann kam sie könnten meinte
er wir müssen weitermachen damit
natürlich noch andere ankommen deswegen
haben wir heute ein fantreffen mit nur
ganz wenigen leuten und wir werden uns
einfach nur unterhalten das ist
eigentlich der primäre grund warum ist
ein oraler fahren aber da wird natürlich
noch vieles anderes passieren ich ziehe
mich jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal zu
ende an wartet dann auch sehr viel herum
kommt und nicht
wer ist der größte im auto ich wer sitzt
hinten im auto
ich schau dir diese sicherheit an ich
muss man alles beibehalten weil ich bei
jedem fall max 2 hinten sind bitte für
die gute sicht die jetzt laut meinem
blog gehabt das liegt daran dass max
lorenz ist blöd male ist mein frühstück
besteht übrigens aus einem apfel und
einem smoothie meine damen und herren
also ich finde da klatschen
wir sind damit zu früh da sind wir zu
spät
meine damen und herren wir sind
angekommen bei der style orava jetzt
mache ich jetzt meine damen und herren
da haben wir gleich die autogrammstunde
ja puschmann instagram wie heißt du hast
nicht cooler schnüffeln und heute war
das drama richtig hinein falsch und
ihrem lot sein
[Musik]
meine damen und herren hier sehen sie
david weist er david nicht kennen sollte
das ist so ca der beschissenes zu
mitarbeiter bei studio 71 damit ist der
beschluss ist die mitarbeiter bei studio
1 70 je ein dummes gesicht reicht schon
ja was ist mit dem bildschirm falsch
gelaufen
das soll so sein
luca und warum stinkt folgen
williams wieder zusammen gefällt sie
denn bisher war das panorama supergeil
heute mit dem stagniert alle nicht
seinen kanal erfolgt laser luca der
beste instructor in deutschland wie
heißt du auf instagram laser luke und du
laser lukas okay wer kennt nicht wolle
was ich übrigens immer trage ist lou
crew als lebenseinstellung sie beim self
moments und die haben für mich natürlich
die passende farbe gewählt denkt was
denkst du darüber
hallo dass für lucas loch von instagram
namen luca bitte sehr gut danke schön
luca alles klar
[Musik]
laser luca
deshalb drücke ich habe gerade mit der
letzten version auf fotos
ich mich um und beamt alle anderen
einfach schon weg wir haben wieder
überzogen von jetzt bin ich hinter der
absperrung ist das nicht geil die
letzten wollen aber ganz gut mit in den
block
[Musik]
die zu beginn gesagt sind wir eigentlich
die mehr hierbei die x te
meet greet
nur wenige zuschauer als er die zehn bis
15 leute
also ohne bilder alles mögliche sondern
ein
das ist der raum das ist tatsächlich
nicht so der schönste raum die wir in
unserem hirn vergleichen
und das finde ich
für die zuschauer ist angekommen fragen
weil leute was jetzt hier von halten
form sind sie denn zum beispiel was für
die auf instagram gemacht habe
die leute brauchen deshalb vor dem
zeitpunkt unserer produkte stehen damit
geschoben und dann müssen andere
direkten später wieder weg
ich würde das nicht mehr von so was
haben natürlich unterhalten sondern nach
nachher irgendwie dabei die hälfte fällt
oben gehört das treffen mit den
zuschauern
nein
die abschlussfeier
daher setzen wir zurück nach köln wo
fragt warum sucht er so schnell voll
gehört dass sein vater habe ich jetzt
nach hause gebracht und hier gucken auch
bundesliga zu ende und werden danach
jetzt schnitzel essen fahren während
sich entscheiden das zwischen seiner
freundin und ein richtig geiles
schnitzel was du zu nehmen
kartoffelsalat zitrone preise wären ein
schnitzel und elia hast du bock hat gut
geschmeckt
ja was ja oder nein als fahrbahn will
man im juni hier im rheinauhafen finde
ich machen in köln zumindest damit das
allerbeste schnitzel das ist jetzt nicht
bezahlt von denen oder irgendwas alter
ich feier dieses low light von der
kamera display der kamera
[Musik]
wir stehen gerade fifa und ich bin es
ehrlich gesagt wissen unfair dass er
jesus drin hat junge der kann über
wasser laufen
warum gehen meine youtube freuen und ich
nachts um halb drei helfen wo es geht
auch an keiner geht ran
ich weiß wir anrufen die uhrzeit wird
jetzt anrufen
liga ist es zwei beachten luca nerven
sie würde ich nicht gehen
meine damen und herren das ist schon
mega spät wir sind ja du darfst an der
stelle den block beenden und einfach
deine hand gegen die linse hauen
[Musik]